[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club round five of the
spring classic here in st. Louis in
Group A every game was drawn thus
grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang keeps the lead
in Group B Belarusian Grandmaster Andre
Gore events one as black against
Brazilian Grandmaster Alexander fear
Gore Yvette's shares the top spots with
Grand Master ox Andra with four rounds
remaining almost anybody could emerge
from the pack
coverage of round six starts now with
over 30,000 dollars and pride on the
line 20 international chess
professionals converge in st. Louis for
the winter wonderland known as the 2018
spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to the
2018 spring chess classic I am Vitaly
namer
and I'm Ben Simon and we missed you so
much that we actually came back 23 hours
since our last broadcast yes happy
daylight-saving time all right
hopefully you didn't have anything
important to do that you missed today
because you forgot to put your clocks
forward an hour there were a couple of
players actually this round who were
about five minutes late Edouard and
Griffin ski you know you don't know if
that's because of you know daylight
saving time or other things but look
these players five minutes with a thirty
second increment you know it shouldn't
affect them too badly right now one of
those games is over and we'll get to
that shortly
but let's take a look at the results
first of all from last night just to
catch up this is round five in our
masters section pretty simple huh
battalion yeah you just
I mean draw fast so everything everybody
drew yeah it's pretty simple and the
standings nothing changes
all draws across the board with
Jeffrey's drawing still in that top spot
it's gonna be tough to take him down
yeah and as far as our challengers
section group II the results from last
night yeah so we do have we did have two
draws and medication versus action
Chandra Ajax stretch nebula against a
wonda Liang but we did have lots of many
of decisive results and they go over its
bidding with black pieces Alexander fear
plead out shank on the palm beat with
the white pieces Erin grab in ski and
the victim is a lefty be to the white
pieces and JJ more Andy and the
standings we'll see that before this
round Chandra and Horvitz have the lead
now catch Ian live is in the lead but
you know that's it's just one game over
so far in the round if you're watching
at us chess champs calm and speaking of
us chess champs calm but just the
absolute best way to watch chess in the
entire world I guess for the past four
or five years and you can check it out
the arch s24 module chess 24 is just an
amazing feature on US chess champ comm
will be having the US Championship
upcoming on that website as as well as a
slew of other tournaments this year
denim you can watch you can watch the
games and the video the commentaries and
you can even you can turn on the engine
analysis I mean what else do you need
yeah got that little thermometer going
up and down yeah but it's it's right
most of the time yeah all the engines
some yeah
so going on right now at us chest champs
calm let's take a look at the pairings
for our masters division yeah so we have
a diary of spirits versus we a ganguly
Lazaro Brazil vs. Alex epitope version
at Cobian versus Jeffrey Zhang Sam
Shanklin is facing yellow available and
remain adored versus Alex only shook and
the game of the day how could you think
anything different it's grandmasters
Barra Cobian and Jeffrey Zhang facing
off there at the top of the leaderboard
in the a group and will be very very
intriguing to see the result of this one
yeah I mean if you can see that that
version of comedies with three points
its enemies playing the white pieces if
he beats jeffrey zhang he's gonna get
the tops that the top seed at this
dentist and board so it's gonna be
interesting to see if that's what
happened or if Jeffrey Zhang will hold
his ground and stay the top it's a game
straight out of the US Chess
Championship I'll tell you that much mhm
and as far as our second group the group
B here are the games going on right now
- one we will tell you that Mel Akashi
on with black has defeated Aaron group
in ski but the other four games are
still in progress
yeah we have under Gore votes versus JJ
Moran da1 delaying versus Victor
McAuliffe ski action Chandra versus
jaxxed embolic and Alexander fear vs.
pre-adoption kinda fun and it's a little
bit tougher to pick the game of the day
I think in this one but I would go with
unrig orbits and JJ Alomar on D three
and a half to two right there so far
okay the tournament format is as follows
we have 210 player round-robin
events the time control is 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves and then after
they complete 40 moves you get a bonus
30 minutes on both clocks for the
remainder of the game there is a 30
second increment from move number one so
that'll help you not flag as they say
and there is a 30 move no draw rule in
effect so the players cannot agree to a
draw before both players thirtieth move
encourage another like this this format
when those round robins because you
basically play everybody so everybody
has an equal chance it's not like an
open just elimin like when you know they
don't really know what you're playing
against or some other players some other
results might decide the winner of huge
is playing against everybody and ya see
what happens yeah there's there's pros
and cons to it right it's the most fair
tournament ever however sometimes you
get kind of these situations where it's
not as climactic as you might want there
might actually be a pretty good finish
to this one we'll see in a few days and
speaking of a few days let's take a look
at the schedule just a few rounds left
four rounds including today and the
rounds start every day at 1:00 p.m.
Central Time the last two days Tuesday
and Wednesday
the rounds will start at 11 a.m. to make
way for the pro chess League
competitions later on in the evening
presented by chess comm the closing
ceremony is not to be broadcast we are
on the air with you every day two and a
half hours after the start of the round
so yeah these games they've been going
on for quite a bit already I'm sure
you've been watching on chess 24 in u.s.
chess champs and the players have a lot
to play for vitality oh yeah the prize
fund for SC the price one for group a
and the total prize fund is $22,000 the
first the top the window of that section
is going to walk with the $6,000 then we
have $4,000 for the second place and
$3,000 for the third place and yeah you
can see the break up of the rest of the
prizes and grupe has a 14 thousand
dollar prize fund there you see it yeah
four thousand dollars for first place
and still everybody gets a prize and
it's important to note that in this
event there are no playoffs so if there
is a tie
first at the end of the event the
players will share the prize money and
that actually goes for all the spots -
mm-hmm
so you add them up divide by three or
however many you have in that tie yeah
much easier okay I want to see a Cobian
and Jean actually yes please all right
version accordion trying to beat Jeffrey
Jean with the white pieces if he beats
him he will get to the top of the
standings so let's see where we are
right now so let's look at this
positional quick it looks like we have a
material equality this position just
going back to more just one move before
that this probably came from the
Grunfeld defense it is characterized by
those pawns here on D phone in e4 white
gets a very strong center however black
gets to attack those set of points with
the bishop and his pawns so let's see
how they started the how the game began
why stop with this move d4 Knight f6 c4
jisuk black is faint chattering has his
Bishop from g7 93 and now d5 if black
plays this move Bishop g7 immediately it
allows white to control the center with
all of all those pawns on e4 and this is
what we call the King's Indian in this
case we do right really white has a very
major grip over the center so this is
why black is making this move d5 to get
some handle but white takes on e4 and
what it takes in place efore a few
exchanges and now Bishop to e3 a very
interesting move
I'm not a girl for player myself but
maybe this is some kind of a novelty I
haven't seen this move before i I know
that the main line goes Knight f3 and
black plays c5 so it's an interesting
idea by version to play
bishop treaty basically proudly
preventing this move pawn to c5 Knight
to d7 was played again black will need
to try somehow to undermine white center
otherwise it's very difficult to find a
plan for for white Bishop c4 c5 Queen to
b3 I'm pretty sure this was a home
preparation the the bleached out the
moves I mean playing that such was like
Bishop Utley Bishop c4 Queen to booty it
was probably a whole population probably
a copy knew that Geoffrey will play the
Grunsfeld okay so black just Castle
Knight f3 and they made a few exchanges
Knight went to b6 once the exchange this
bishop on c4 obviously white is not
ready to give up his to Bishop to Bishop
Bishop e6 Queen before rock to see 8th
and now white is has cancelled here
probably queen takes is 7 will not be
will be just too risky
let's try to figure out why probably the
Queen might just take the Queen and rook
fe8 and then the bishop will go
somewhere and those two points on equal
and default although they are very
strong in the middle but they're also
hanging sometimes in them I'm quite
afraid in for white so we see this
pattern again just as yesterday the
window when the players offer something
but it's actually in the poisoned pawn
and castle was played rook Bishop c4
rook fev1 we have a few exchange of the
nine to see for attacking this Bishop on
8 3 root 2 d1 black decides not to take
the bishop it plays Queen d7 just to
defend this pawn on on b7 and also
bringing all his pieces into the game
Bishop to c1 yeah so this this move just
intended to preserve the
and probably transpose him to some some
other spots like maybe a four or g 5a 5b
v okay so this is where a Jeffersons you
know what I know you came here to beat
me but I have some aids in my sleeve as
well playing for definitely playing for
some shop game rook to c2 rook FD 8 and
h3 was played h6 of trade and now d5
white is trying to gain some small space
in the center and ecigs
and I think this is the current position
that we have on the chess board you have
to be quite honest I think it's pretty
close to equal of course white cannot
take this pawn this is because the
whites rookie on d1 is hanging it's not
so easy to find for why the next move in
my opinion I mean probably I would be
thinking about moving this Bishop to f4
the bishop on on c1 just feels like he
did not get his full potential so Bishop
to f4 just putting the bishop on a more
active square and maybe black is gonna
play something like g5 before actually
before it's not possible but maybe a
four lots lots and lots of ideas for
both of the players and although I think
it is close to equality but I think it's
gonna be a decisive decisive resolve
this is at least my bet let's look at at
times we see that Geoffrey has more time
30 minutes against eight minutes for
volusion it is version Coburn's move and
he's probably thinking well you know I
made this preparation at home it went
well at the beginning but Geoffrey so
all the correct moves how to fight
against it and now he's thinking well
was it you know was it the correct
decisions for me to play into this
variation and it looks like they're both
look very determined
you know this is the fourth time that
they've played a classical game Maskull
rated game they drew a couple times in
the u.s. championship but the last time
I think it was the last time that var
and Jeffry met it was actually at last
year's Spring Classic the tournament
that var actually won he is the
defending Group A champion and Varga
feeted Jeffry as black Oh Geoffrey is
still winless over the US Championship
runner-up vara Cobian that should be an
intriguing game here Stefan Lee and also
I saw a flash across the screen there
while you were switching game Sam
Shanklin and yarrow jariabek have drawn
their game yeah so this is the final
position in the game we have a rock end
game probably white would just take this
pawn on a four black would take this
pawn on b2 and then I'm gonna come here
for four this pawn on on g5 and it looks
it looks pretty much like it although
black can keep his pawn for example
something like rook air-five king of six
but yeah we know that it usually in
grandmaster games such end games will
end in a draw I mean Yahoo can still
play this out but especially the fact
that those two pawns are not connected
they're just isolated pawns it's gonna
be very very difficult for black to to
win this so that they just get to save
their time and effort probably prepare
for the next game I would like to visit
our group be friends our game of the day
over there between unrig orbits and Ally
Morandi okay the game of the day and
Group B yeah so far looks like we have
more decisive games in the in do B so
let's see definitely this is you know
what I'm speaking about
we have much more material well we have
just some imbalance in the pawn
structure it looks like white has some
edge just because of this pawn on d6
definitely a major threat to blacks
pieces pawn will be pushed summers at
some point to c8 right now it is white
to move first of all we immediately see
this move 97 trying to fork the Queen
the rook and the bishop at the same time
however luckily for black he has this
intermediate move week we called
intermediate move in between moves a
check Queen to b6 probably check and
then if the King moves probably to h1
well now the rook can swing to c8 this
is pretty pretty interesting a moment
because suddenly black is the one who
gets to attack this this pawn on c6 and
time tonight so if the knight let's say
takes this this bishop on e6 I wonder if
we can take the spot on c6 first might
be a bit dangerous because of Bishop to
c5 you can also take just the knight on
on e6 and why do we have to figure out
what do I do the spot on c6 I cannot put
this pawn to c7 because I'm hanging my
bishop on this X so just in two moves
really this de-spawn from being an asset
can become a liability for white it's
gonna be very interesting to see
obviously this this squirrel and see it
is very well protected by three of
blacks pieces so it's not going to be so
easy for white to win this position but
I wonder you know this neither would be
five nights are usually the best block
eaters
so if Y just plays this move Knight to
d4 black eating this pawn to five
defending this pawn attacking this
bishop on e6
I really like White's position although
his king is a slightly exposed on this
diagonal I do like White's position I
wish my phone would be on f2 but on the
other hand this pawn on f3 takes control
over the e4 square not allowing the
Black Knight to come in and I don't know
it's just difficult very difficult in
such positions for black to find a plan
you know I I'm it's pretty much you know
you have to keep yourself other defense
and you can do it for a move to moves
maybe 5 moves but it takes lots of
energy and an effort from the pronet
players and I think that this position
is so it's it's better for white but we
will see some some developments during
time pressure
we're getting there we're getting there
ok let's look at some other games that
we we have it looks like a wonder Lang's
in trouble against Victor McCallum ski
elsewhere in Group B Victor has some
tough to stop pawns coming down here
look at this yeah yeah you know we will
I remember a round one Aaron grab in ski
was playing against a wonder Liang and
you know Aaron was was was winning
against the Wonder but I wonder is the
top seed by rating and know he's such a
talented chess player and and I wonder
if the faculty that it did not go so
well for him in the round one it
affected him psychologically because it
looks like he does not have so much so
much luck so far
you know so this is what we call
momentum it just it's it's very
important in chance especially when you
lose a game - you know just to kind of
forget it and restart yourself from the
beginning so at this point after Evo was
played white played this move Bishop to
c2 going back but I really don't I mean
first of all black is a is a pawn up now
if the bishop would be on d2 if white
would have a dark square Bishop then I
would say white has very good chances
for it
because it would be an opposite color
Bishop endgame in this case it's a it's
the same color blush of endgame
it's it is black to move and although
Victor has last time it is very easy to
play here for black you can you can
either push the pawn to e3 or just start
marching your King and let's let's look
at this position if I March my king then
I'm afraid that the White King isn't in
time to create a blockade and it's not
going to be as easy for for black to to
use his material advantage on the other
hand maybe black and try to play this
move
III immediately just to just to try and
play against this King on g1 so let's
try to make a move King to f1 tries to
play King e2 and get this pawn on e too
but then but I can play this with Bishop
to f3 hmm and now all those squares next
to the King are taking away from him and
to be honest I don't see a way for white
just any kind of a way to save this I
mean how do i how do I save my position
I see that Viktor just stood up which
means that he probably made a move and
let's see what what did he make and
Italy I mean yes I mean we we hear the
name from the interview yesterday from
Victor he is a very great calculator
kids calculating is so well yeah so
Italy you know he made this woman just
within two minutes III and I bet that
he's looking he's looking to play after
king of one Bishop f3 and how do we what
do the skin it's so passive the blacks
idea batsman is pretty simple March the
King so no I predict that we will see
this march of the King over using
another pawn black will public hit
another passport over this side and
although white has some advantage on the
on the King side
but the H&G ponds I don't feel like they
going to be in any danger to black so I
think that this will be a decisive game
well Victor will probably be there
wonder do you think that a wonder is
gonna try to play this out probably I
mean it's it's not finished yet and
that's he we are in moon about 36
probably yeah probably he will try to do
something maybe Bishop d3 king of six
let's try to exchange the bishops
because if that exchanges the bishops
now why who take this Paul III so he
might go for this variation but again
black does not have to exchange the
bishops I can keep them keep the bishops
may be Bishop d5 Bishop d3 King e5 King
it - and now king d4 so the King comes
to d4 and then he's gonna push c4 c3 and
in that case polyp that can already
exchange the bishops at some point even
Bishop f3 is coming some sacrifices I
think we're gonna see at least five more
moves in this game but if things if
things gonna go as we as we predicted I
don't think that the one that is gonna
try to save this pretty ugly position
yeah it just gonna be too painful I
don't see any chances for him what about
Victor Michalowski if he assuming he
wins this he's gonna be in the lead and
a wonder is gonna be staring at - - yeah
for draw still winless in this event a
wonder won last year's Spring Classic
Group B section but that may as well be
ancient history if you look at this one
right here not his best performance yeah
we're gonna have a change of champions
yes
in Group E yeah what it's worth right I
got a spreadsheet I got all the winners
don't worry guys I got you go okay let's
look at some other games we have lots of
action going on we know that we did have
a game finished medic
catchy on orbit around your bin ski yeah
unfortunately it looks like Aaron is not
having the best chess tournament in his
life he did well it's a very tough field
for a Boston he is the the bottom C to
replace with the Grandmaster James
Tarzan he accepted on a couple days
notice so we give him all the credit in
the world but it is it is very tough
being the bottom seat here but
everything to gain though yeah so Aaron
started with this Fancher than his
bishop and then c4 we have there its
countless opposing to the ready defense
he did get the center let's see what
what happened well where did it go wrong
d5 this is pretty much all tea overnight
c96 and black is again same same thing
as in the green field white gets this
strong strong central pawn but how
strong is it you know black is is kind
of coming here and start to attack in
the center exchanging a few PA few pawns
sorry few exchanges why decided not to
exchange the Queen's because if he would
exchange the Queen's it does look like
black gets the whole of the D file so in
if Queen c2 queen in a seven-night - d -
you know I wonder if if this would be
the best chance for for Aaron maybe
somehow just exchange the Queen's and
you know maybe try to play safe for
chess because yeah at least that's
that's how it works for me maybe after a
few losses I would I would try to just
stop the bleeding yeah exactly at all I
mean he's thankful for all these things
for win always think hey and there it is
Mika Lipsky has defeated in Wonderland
yeah just saw the handshake there yeah
yeah so yeah so he didn't so Wando
decided even not to play in Alamo
I mean both of them are very experienced
just--there's they understand the
consequences of such an endgame yeah
okay let's look at some other games
that's going on right now
how about group a Roman Edouard and Alex
owner shook looks like there might be
some happenings here in favor of the
Frenchman all right so let's see what is
going on here
Eduardo remains playing the white pieces
versus Alex on this yoke what do we have
here so white is basically is having
those two pieces night and Bishop versus
a rope and upon now technically it is
materially balanced right because a
knight and a bishop of that three points
so we have six points versus a rook and
upon but we know that they usually took
pieces of valued a little bit more just
because of the cooperation between the
pieces as much better however if the
rook gets the gets to be active you know
if if black can play here route d8 and
activate the rook and try to get some
activity in some cases the Roccat upon
and might might might get to try to get
risky for white now the immediate
problem for black is this pawn on f6 so
why is starting this this pawn of six so
I assume that Alexander on the issue
gets thinking thinking right now okay do
I just defend this pawn with King g7 but
it's gonna give white more time to think
about his move more time to to activate
his pieces to to make the move somewhere
else or do I sacrifice this pawn of six
which is a double pawn you know it's
it's does not look so so good this pawn
structure and I immediately play room d8
unfortunately white will take on f6 with
a check
kingi seven and now okay let's just try
to move the nights over 94 but now
really black and swing his rook over
Rudy one Czech king of two and now maybe
York to be one and now in this case if
if black does succeed in activating his
stroke I think that black has pretty
good chances and this position is
probably being played for three results
I'm not even sure who's going to win
here it's gonna be it's gonna be have to
decide it in time tank trouble as we see
we have 31 moves made so far and I think
that Alex initially did make a move and
he did play Rudi at him he does go for
this pawn sacrifice to activate his his
rook
I think that now Edward Romain is
thinking here do I do I have set this
pawn f6 it looks all sounded kind of
sketchy that you know again vessel give
me this free porn so what else can he do
we can either take the pawn or he can
also defend the night by playing Bishop
to h3 and yeah so the bishop on g2 is
actually not as not as strong at the
moment so transferring the bishop on HT
really creates a barrier for the rook
you know how do i what I do with the
stroke now I mean what I do with the
King what are the with my pieces King
just seven will be played but that does
not look any good
rook e8 cannot be played because Y can
just capture here on f6 with this with
this amazing fork and that's just
completely waiting for white so King do
some real probably be played and let's
assume Y to play something like e for
and after rook e8 Bishop to f5 I mean
just look at this position the king is
trapped there is no way for him to make
any progress the rook is trapped as well
oh my god the eye I mean the rock indeed
is not doing
anything you can come to e7 but it's not
such a active spot for him and the idea
is that they cannot come to e6 and
cannot go to e5 because those squirrels
are taken by the bishop and the night
so really all all blacks pieces are trap
I really it's very difficult for you
know for black to find some contemplate
you can try to play h4 but then I'm
going to play before King h6 I'm going
to try to release my king from this side
but even then I can add a plate h4 or I
can even just stop bringing my king over
when my key reaches b6 that is it that
is going to be game over I'm just gonna
just snap those pawns of the board and
just Queen Windows though the a and the
B pawn it's just in this position black
will be hopeless so let's see so it's
gonna be interesting to see what if
Eduardo main will take this pawn on f6
or will decide to play more positionally
with Bishop to h3 you know it is kind of
a time trouble he has ten minutes on the
clock versus 20 over Alexander but this
decision is not supposed to be so
difficult to play Bishop HD versus
taking the pawn of six I'm pretty sure
he's gonna go for the positional
advantage restriction of the of the
opponent's pieces and yeah if he finds
this move Bishop to HD I would say it's
pretty good decipher he's played it he
did yeah that's what we gonna be a tough
oh is that blocking our view the board
here exactly
try recognize this shirt right actually
romance wearing a pink nice pink shirt
today yeah we had one one pink yeah
think they hear it that was long ago
yeah very very pinky alrighty so let's
go to some other games that so we are at
Group A let's go to would be well who
else is playing who B let's
look at Chandra and stim Puglia oh I see
yeah yeah great mindset uh yes I read
your thoughts um okay what has happened
here and just to go what move before
let's just snap this pawn on beef on b2
okay very interesting I mean the point
is defended by the rock was so what is
going on here but before we go to the
position I just want to get your
attention to the clock action Chando
less than a minute this is this is
something that a lot of junior players
have trouble with the the time pressure
that getting into chronic time trouble
yeah and this is something that Chandra
is familiar with hopefully you knows how
to work with it it oh yeah definitely
hopeful hopefully you know start to play
bullet games because we'll give some of
the one-minute games and there's a
30-second increments not it's still
going I mean I mean it's such a decision
do I take this night or not now let's
make it let's try to make ask this
decision take obviously black wants to
take on c3 and now look at this this is
hanging this not only is hanging this
rope on because hanging this district on
on a1 is hanging oh my god now as far as
I remember Akshay Chandra is at the top
of the list right now right yeah this is
gonna hurt yeah especially with white
yes and wow what what a complicated
that's what I was saying that last time
that people on the bottom of the list
will try to engage with the top of this
to to to outrun them and get some
chances for that first prize because you
know it's a because eventually if you
win fifth place I think or sixth place
or ten place there is almost no
difference in the prize money right but
yeah so if you're on the bottom half of
the of the standings I mean it's pretty
much similar so you really have to have
to jump there you have to sacrifice and
play some some some very technical and
sharp chess to try to get yourself on to
the top you have nothing to lose right
so and we have all the information about
this German guys at us chess champs calm
you can see the prize fund in the full
schedule everything you need to know
about this
to field round-robin event right why do
I do can do they have information about
us we should put some information about
us that over there we got credits on
chess 24 you know but Akshara he he won
his first two games he's sitting at plus
two and this would be his first defeat
in this event yeah
and as you can see we do have him a move
because well we were speaking more than
a minute and so he did make him move
when he had only 17 seconds left on the
clock so which brought his clock to 47
seconds and he did he played f4 Wow
why did what is sharp or the sharp over
again we see we see this idea I'm not
taking any any of your pieces I think
it's too dangerous
he relies on the fact that his opponent
if finished in block he be calculated
correctly so he played f4 the idea of a4
is pretty simple
I want to counter-attack this night on
on e5 but also the Queen here is
defending the city pawn I'm pretty sure
this was this was kind of a blunder here
that he made so night to d3 let's go
back what happened here in this position
if we just go five five moves ago I mean
look at this Knight this is what this is
what I call the night march right I mean
there so the knight came to d7 the knife
came to c5 and then the knight came to
d3 and then the knight go want to be too
don't we know this don't we didn't
really discuss this role of not moving
at one piece too many times for a lot of
steak yeah yeah yes for itself and it's
still alive
probably why
see him move again that'll be very
interesting and Stanwyck did make did
make his move he played he played Queen
takes on c3 now he played Knight d2 d3
Bishop takes and Queen takes c3 he
really wanted to get this pawn because
really if you get this pawn the pawn on
City was the glue was the glue of the
position really defended the defendant
the night here on d4 but also the
rookies attacked
wow this screen this screen is mean some
trouble for y time yeah I would be
sweating a lot right now if I will be
action Chandra especially with 34
seconds they are moved number 29 he has
to move he has to make ten moves 11
moves in no pretty much half a minute
pretty much if you even if you give half
a minute to move you're gonna get I was
just at 6 minutes or 5 minutes yeah
that's not so not so easy to make 10
moves in about 5 minutes
this position is crumbling for action
exactly so I mean time aside that's just
exacerbating the problem yeah and yeah
I've got to say that Ajax 10 block is
taking his time here which is a good
thing right we don't want to see people
rush I don't know some people trying to
play on time it just makes make some
move just to play on time but he is
taking his time after action Channel
play this move f5 is figuring out do I
really want to defend this bishop on g6
or I can strike him while we're just
taking I mean look at this position I
can take any one of those pieces the
1983 look on d2 Queen takes d4 it's it's
like a candy store over there
okay so let's let's start with it with a
stroke on d2 why can't I just take the
stroke pawn takes on g6 probably will be
played but now I'm gonna take this
Bishop here with a queen and you can
take it on f7 rook takes f7 but now
probably Queen exchanges if the quickest
equation so we saw it a huge amount of
exchanges but in the end what black will
be left with the rook and two points now
for a knight on a three that's you know
that's that's just this is dead lost
time there's no way for for white to
make you know any any chance even
nothing time pressure it's just just
black is winning so yeah whatever what
if like takes this line with a check on
on d4 let's try to move our King away
King h1 and actually that's two King h2
just in case I wanna and now what can I
do I can can I just take this Bishop on
the tree I can just take everything I
mean I think that everything is just
crumbling just yeah just everything just
falls apart white the whites queen is
aligned in front of our King but
remember that this this rook only seven
just in just in case is here to protect
the king I don't see any tricks for
white I I think it's I think it's almost
it's almost lost I mean yeah it's it's a
shame because just five moves ago if we
go back to this this position white
played let's go here I really like this
disposition I me actually white position
is not so bad like has an isolated pawn
white did play this move 22 that is to
bring the other okay now after h5
something here went wrong in my opinion
white could just probably just play rook
81 maybe bring that this night over back
to the game we know that the nights are
not such so good that's all not so
effective on the edge of the board so
Knight coming back here to e3 auto
before I would really love to see this
Knight coming back into play and those
trucks are aligned in the center
but instead that we see those those
moves like a rogue d1 then who enough to
just some waiting moves you know I was
I'm wondering if actual Chandler just
wanted just to make some wedding moves
or maybe maybe it was some kind of a
draw for now maybe just queen f2 and
then a Queen d7 and a draw but he didn't
realize that ejection bullet can
prepared yeah right and that's certainly
not on the table anymore yeah it looks
like a few moves well played and it
looks like black did take on on d2 David
the rook and why did take the bishop on
g6 now I'm expecting black just to snap
that bishop of the board other with a
knight all with the Queen I mean yeah
that's what else can happen here if I
take with an idea you can black and
white play this move Knight a5 create
some chaos that's looking here then my
route can come here to e1 to check him
and the game is over yeah Oxshott has
resigned
well congratulations dejection of Lueck
oh yes it's weird
yeah it's against the top-seeded so this
is actions first tasted defeat in this
tournament thus far I mean he's not out
by any estimation yeah but if I could
complicates the standings yes it does
Group II has been such a turmoil
exciting turmoil yeah right that's gonna
be really yeah gonna be very very
interesting to to speak to - Jax - Jack
about this this facet in the game today
indeed in three wins for black so far
and groovy hmm very interesting a great
day for black like today yes yes let's
see then what we have left we have
Alexander fear and in this position we
have PD playing with black and as far as
I can count black has the material
advantage again I really like this just
rule coming in to see Juan says hello
and not into White's Kingdom and I like
I like black I mean the white does have
two bishops let's not underestimate the
power of the two bishops but if black
can bring the other rook to d1 I mean he
has lots of lots of threats here on the
bishop I like black chances what is what
is going on here and what about our last
game we have an Tiger of it's playing
white against JJ morandi yes last game
in Group A and Group E that is in this
case well we actually already discussed
this this position we left this position
we're somewhere around this after Queen
Asus and we're wondering a word did not
go denied denied stay there but then he
did go afterwards to d4 really like I
really like this this outpost for the
night we block it buckling this de-spawn
kind of like you know it's it's from all
sides why this is coming over there
this pond on c6 is is very dangerous and
a few other moves were played nightly to
have Quintus III what is trying to
exchange the Queen's and I do prefer
white here again because of this past
policy 6 however however let's not
forget that let's not forget about time
pressure guys in a minute
that's the man that we have well luckily
400 this is move number 38 yeah so it's
not that not that hardcore right - I
mean 2 moves only got left and it's
pretty easy to make the moves here I
mean I can I can offer something like
roof to see - maybe attacking the Queen
I can also just play this move c7 I all
need to figure out other any sacrifices
here I saw their stake but the King can
they just take and there are no more
checks because everything is the fact
this bishop on d6 is doing such a good
job defending all the dark squares such
a good defender any and the potential
made on g3 as well and that is true
goodness for the bishop yes so this is
this might be the only game and good be
that we will see white winning the only
another white has to save the other for
this round very very exciting with these
high level games it's typically you you
have very very strong grandmasters
saying I come into win with white and I
come in to draw with black you go just
that that first move advantage is is a
lot for these top players you know it's
the difference between a half points so
you volley the ball a certain way when
you're black and you do it a little bit
harder when you're white black is on the
defense so three wins for black is a big
deal
in this group be here today yeah yeah
especially the then the next games of
those players they're gonna be white now
right so I mean you can win with black
that's a big advantage I mean I don't
know how it breaks down with who has how
many whites and blacks left but it's not
going to be even remember there are
player this is a 1980s it's just a very
slight difference in advantage and it's
all about how I believe it was a random
seed drawing I was always wondering how
do you guys do it is it like in the
lottery you have like a bowl like a with
the balls like you have to say a name
okay he gets number one somebody gets
number two well actually it depends on
the tournament so for this it's like
pretty low-key right so we're probably
like I don't know draw names out of a
hat whatever might come er feels like
doing right for the Ziegfeld Cup and
like the rapid and blitz they'll have
like you know Rolex watches or something
like and they'll have like numbers on
the bottom or Kasparov's new book
something like you know the players get
to go away with a souvenir of tattoo you
know so it's a nice little drawing and
basically all it is is half the field
has white more than black and half the
field has black more than white so it's
a minimum difference it's got to happen
though when there's an odd number of
rounds yeah yeah definitely I always I'm
always like in intention with any before
I play those those those two limits
because I really want to get more white
and the ones who get the white other
players to get numbers 1 to 5 yeah
you're getting more white and number 6
to 10 you get the more blacks right and
that's that's all the seeding is you
know because if you have a tournament
like a knockout okay if you are the top
seed where it should be done by rating
not by chance but if you're the top seed
you're gonna be playing the bottom seed
typically in the first round you know
that's the that's a perk of being a top
seed in the round-robin event yeah it's
just you know you're in one half or the
other half yeah go and play against
everybody okay let's jump to enough of
group goobie we've seen enough of a
bloody results over there alright I'm
gonna get a heart attack over here so
let's look
Group a group much more balanced games
right again because of their rating
differences are much smaller look at a
Cobian and Jeffrey Zhang oh yeah this is
of the utmost importance right now our
game of the day of course a alright we
have a few developments let's see where
we got left here I think this is pretty
much the the the moment that we left the
game like wiper d5 tried to expand in
the center in e6 and I said that I don't
like this bishop on c1 so much so maybe
I should just devolve the bishop on the
four white played h4 interesting what is
the idea of maybe just maybe to play h5
and somehow to weaken the black skin
black played just Queenie eight I really
like this move Queen eight very
cold-blooded I don't care about you you
know you your plan about h5 I'm just
making this useful move because I'm
basically getting out getting my Queen
out of the stroke so now I'm ready to
capture here on d5 so this is this is
the whole point the growth of the fans
you know now I want to get this this
week pawn on d5 rook e1 was saying you
try to get your queen out no I'm
following you so he took upon takes and
now Queen back to d7 row 31 again this
might be some kind of a draw offer
because if black plays Queen eight rook
e1 we might see a repetition of moves by
the way if we see a repetition of moves
before move number thirty right three
three four the petition would that be a
drunken based yeah that's an exception
right so the 30 move rule says that you
can't agree to a draw just the wall
further but if the draw is inevitable
you know let's say that somehow it
wouldn't happen but let's say like it
was just two kings left on the board
before move 30 it's a draw
it's inevitable a repetition would mean
that you can't tell the players not to
repeat you know it's gonna happen so
it's just agreeing to a drama
I wonder what it would happen if
somebody's still no still offers a draw
to somebody before move number 30 and
they agree so do you just make them make
them continue playing yeah yeah that's
what it is the arbiter will have to say
that that was not a valid draw offer and
they will continue with their game so
it's kind of unusual of course in
because the players know what move it is
they're taking notations yeah so they
might just forget you know we forced
them to play chess yes it looks like the
players are playing a lot more it's like
the game is over
okay here's oh that's let's see what
happened in their game please do the
game of the day Bishop f4 was played and
it looks like
hmmm interesting I wonder I wonder what
what is there is all because Jeffry Jean
has won Geoffrey did win okay because I
see that Bishop f4 was the last move and
I'm like is that where your notation
stops because I do have more moves here
okay to the freshmen board Bishop a4 aha
every eight to just one more move makes
all the difference I mean very exciting
position actually because now if white
can take this rook on b8 but white black
takes this rook but hey I'm also
promoting by the way so I get a queen
and and what what else can I do if i
move this roof somewhere let's move it
well I can't move it on the B file
because again black is going to get a
queen if I move it to its a d1 or c1
what now black is going to take on on b7
and and next move he is going to promote
and that makes Geoffrey Jean still their
leader with how many points yeah he's
pulling away he has four and a half out
of six games right now
oh my god he's unstoppable no yeah it
definitely plus three right now for
Geoffrey Zhang and this tournament it is
his now yeah it didn't he hasn't
clinched it by any means but yeah if he
the other players you know if it's out
of their hands
yeah he's got a hole over the father so
Varrick open and only shook were they
well the ones who could top the second
and third seed yeah right now live the
live standings have Geoffrey at the top
and then a point and a half behind him
owner shook Shanklin a Cobian and share
a book a point a half behind it oh my
god yeah that's that's pretty major in
those two limits and we have three more
rounds to go after that andrey after
today yeah and so even that's a even
even if Jeff Lee draws of his all of his
games which were gonna get him point and
a half that's the point then half
leaveth he has now he's just he can just
draw all his way through the to the
victory to the first place it might
share with somebody but I remember that
you were asking me
I think it's like round number three or
four but he was on the lead
it was just the beginning of the lead
you ask me should you just draw his
games and I was like no no I mean that's
that's probably not a good idea still
write it early right but now when he
would beating vara Cobian and getting a
point and a half
leave me the head oming I mean he could
just come in and just drop however this
is illegal
he has to play right so it's good if we
have this rule yes a for a draw so you
might be playing just something more
conservative yes now there's not as
aggressive but I mean I mean great
results for him it would you know
beating vara Cobian with the black
pieces from the dallas-fort Worth
Metroplex Jeffrey Zhang looking like he
may win this group when the Masters
section yeah yeah great position okay
who do we have let's do it let's look at
Alexander only shook against Edward
Romain and we left it here after Brooke
to the eighth Bishop HD was played King
g7 this is exactly what we were
discussing
Bishop to h3 he white decided not to
take on on this point of six kind of
kind of goes against all the principles
that we learned you know usually we
would say just take take take take
capture everything but here we see that
no just just stop you know some eating
too much it's not so good as well right
so you know you have to pace yourself so
King g7 King f2 was played h5 that's
exactly what we said Bishop of five and
five and probably played the king is
going there black is trying to create
some kind of play for the rook but why
is played before almost exactly what we
expected and again if Wyatt is going
just to play something like king f4 or
king or king g3 and then just snap this
pawn on h3 with this rook has nothing to
do this is just yeah I I don't see how
Alexander on issue is going to be saving
this
this game and yeah so alexandre melnik
was one of the players who can still
maybe somehow to to get to to jelly but
if he loses then let's see so Eduardo
main has how many points right now Roman
is actually tied for last he has two out
of five but we say tied for last I mean
there's a lot of players tied up right
now I mean right they is so close in
solo so probably you know if Jeff Lee is
watching this game right now I mean he
is definitely rooting forward well
remain right he doesn't want any
competition form from the other seeds if
next to him and what okay well well
today we're gonna see potentially both
Kobe on and owner shook be kind of cut
down from the lead yeah very surprising
game ever very surprising results today
I gotta say I like to make my
predictions sometimes by the weather
do you have you noticed today I just I
woke up in the morning it was really
nice not not so bad and then just an
hour later storm snow rain was going to
miss the rain it didn't mean to me it
was just beginning to look a lot like
Christmas yeah I know exactly just like
all the other snow but you know I've
been teaching a few lectures ago so we
have lots of chest lectures for
beginners for advanced chess players
here at the st. Louis chess club we had
one at 1:00 p.m. and 2:00 p.m. and you
know I was I was telling the staff yes
this is this is the famous kids classes
that Ben Feingold has told all of you
about the 1 p.m. class - yeah
and so I was telling the staff well you
know usually with a bad weather we're
probably gonna see much less students
coming in but no my class we had over 25
students in both of them so they will
Trek out in fact sometimes I don't think
there's a cause and effect here I don't
think there's a correlation because
sometimes with the nastiest weather
people will Trek out from West County
and Far East and then I'm here for these
classes you'll have 30
people in the room yeah people people I
was discussing with some of the students
there is actually driving him here for
an hour just to get to those classes and
I mean the good thing about those
classes that even after the class is
finished you can just go over there and
just play chess we have lots of chess
tables lots of lots of players very
interesting they can the players
spectators are allowed to go in that
playing area obviously they have to be
very quiet and no cell phones no cell
phones right
we don't have metal detectors for this
tournament but they do have to submit
their cell phones I I will have to
correct you there vitaly actually we
don't see at the beginning of the round
1:00 p.m. every day might come ER with
his wand he has a little the detector
wands so that's actually pretty
entertaining sometime yeah but these
ding is for the plate for the players
the beginning right and then the
spectacle scan yeah I remember that he
was he was one day you cannot start your
game unless you're wounded yes the
championship by the way is always like
really entertaining because all the kids
that come in you never know what they're
gonna have their pocket is like like
five packs of gum or laughs little
trinkets and stuff like here it's it's
it's not as exciting the Junior
Championship we should make a segment
it's like what's in the pocket yeah yeah
I wonder if so we're gonna see one of
those you know x-ray machines like in
the airport
it's just route just swing around you as
expensive no yeah but I mean to be
honest when you have those big chess
tournaments especially like world
champions Championships can include them
antics infield Cup I mean you have you
know hundreds of thousands of dollars on
the line and every move can can make an
impact so you know we take those
measures anti-cheating measures pretty
seriously right if you haven't been
buying the st. Louis chess club we
certainly encourage you to come on by
the first visit is always free and we
might even just be able to give you a
tour show you some of the cool parts of
the chess campus you made the World
Chess Hall of Fame across the street the
Chess Club where all the tournaments
happen we have a diner next door
actually work technically at the
kingside diner right now doing
commentary so they have some great food
there
inside swinger I know I can doing this
commentating in there I can just smell
it yeah it's a great king size and the
st. Louis chess campus now so what is
going on here I see that priyadarshan
Kanter pans looking still really great
against Alexander fear in Group B let's
look at the game that we haven't
discussed yet so yeah Ganguly against
Darius perch and group a let's see what
what this is what what is going on here
looks like Darius okay so we have
material equality so yeah I can do it
definitely is dating on time with the 56
minutes versus 15 minutes for Darius
they made time control
they didn't make time go to but as you
see it's it's kind of strange because
there is there's only 15 minutes on the
clock oh no he was supposed to get half
an hour so that tells me that he spent
at least fifteen minutes on the for the
move right now this is one hour 41 so
what has happened let's look from the
beginning efore c5 we have substance
iliyan is six sometime out of 94 93 27
this is pretty much old theory why it
has this idea of each other the bishop
has beside in many openings takes takes
94 this is pretty much old theory white
gets some some more space with those two
points
c5 Queen e2 e3 Bishop e2 well we have
seen this double fan chatter of the
bishops 9702 d1 Bishop c6 Knight city oh
yeah like White's position you know it's
a what is not betting on it and you know
it's not risking anything probably I can
just double up my roofs on the deef I'll
put some pressure on a d6 pawn y can
also try to play F 4 or 5 on the other
hand the black also does not have any
major problems here
Bishop f6 was played night to be one
interesting very interesting very
interesting moment he'll why decides to
exchange his dark square bishop now I've
got to say that it's it's a bit strange
that he decided to exchange the duck to
a bishop because the dark swirl bishops
usually in such positions white wants to
keep the task of bishops as you can see
in this in this in this position white
has all almost all his pawns on light
squares which means that he this Bishop
on g2 is not feeling so comfortable he
feels cool very closed which makes this
Bishop on b2 on the other hand much more
active so exchanging this Bishop is was
a bit strange to me but he brings a
knight back a4 basically we have so
black is trying to to attack on the
Queen side and the idea of the of this
kind of am i guess minority attack for
for black here is to create some kind of
a witness to push a for take on b3 and
then swing his ropes to the B file and
attack on on on b3 so this is kind of
the idea of a five and a four and the
white is and is play play e5 obviously
white is trying to get some counter play
we see a few exchanges Queen afore Queen
Queen to f3 so a very very interesting
game to be following but now we have a
guest
in a room and I'm part of to welcome
ejects the Bullock thank you for joining
us
congratulations on you win today first
of all your first win but you're playing
with black pieces right most of the
black pieces actually won today in Group
B so congratulations and you you played
the you game against action Chandra who
who lost and I was just saying before
before we started around that at this
point of the tournament the players who
are on the bottom of the list day you
don't have much to lose
so you have you know you play them over
a risky chess right and you know
actually Chandra he was on top of the of
the standings I'm assuming that you
prepare for the game right I mean he's
yeah so yeah so you're for mccrane by
the way yeah okay is it your first time
here in st. Louis
yeah first time how do you what do you
think you'll like it it's pretty
interesting City yeah also very
interesting weather we're not expecting
that that's weather but luckily for you
you'd live a the hotel here right just
at the house just next to the Chess Club
which is yeah very very convenient right
and we have the Hall of Fame of
Starbucks to keep your caffeine going
right so yeah so welcome to the st.
Louis thank you
so let's let's jump into you again today
so you're playing the black pieces and
so you expecting him to play e4 or your
kind of place before but sometimes plays
d4 I wasn't so sure yeah to confuse us
yeah so you prepared to both of them you
play d6 and we go to the French defense
night to d2 I was kind of expected
mm-hmm c5 just pretty much the main line
nygean 396 takes takes Bishop e5 pretty
much theory as far as I remember you can
also take on c5 first but just a
transposition of moves and now Queen c7
this this was definitely a whole
population yeah
was he I guess he didn't know this move
mm-hmm
surprise yeah if you think about here in
this moment a lot yeah maybe like 15
minutes
time pressure maybe maybe by the way
maybe this move what got to the point I
mean you obviously you're not winning
but because of this you know the stress
and well you you come here and suddenly
the opponent surprises you it wastes a
lot of time so good but anyway so the
position is not so complicated right so
so let's see screen to check Bishop to
e2 yeah yeah so it doesn't want to
exchange Queens otherwise you simply
draw try six take on she takes a 5s
already not the best move I mean just a
short customs a little k1 it's more
ambitious right and then you have to
figure out well what am I doing with my
Queens and so him taking on c5 kind of
help to you okay always nice when the
poet helps us a queen takes on c5 castle
now Bishop e7 just regular development
was played and i bt 26 Bishop e5 this is
all pretty standard c3 so basically
widespread is probably to block it this
pawn on d5 but on the other hand you
have the quantifiable space and they
have my bishop on a5 right so okay f e8
and I assume that your faith is those
positions many times before with black
so you kind of knew where to put the
pieces in pretty simple yeah position is
pretty simple
yeah bishop g6 pretty simple it's not
let's see it's a bishop F Knight e4 was
played here so basically you offer him
to exchange the bishops
okay well but my night only four is so
strong mm-hmm he played f3 I don't know
I'm not sure about this move because it
weakens king position right yeah but I I
so maybe he wasn't was he
afraid that he's we've got like you
can't take enough to like it let's say
that I make a random of Roxy one can you
like maybe take you is that too much or
rooky eight first and then maybe a night
except two but I'm not sure but it does
look a little bit scary for him so yeah
f3 maybe like maybe Bishop have still
something would be yeah Bishop f3 maybe
it was better so f3 Knight going back to
f6 Bishop f1 9595 Knight dis not coming
to before yeah I'm not sure it's this
transposition of the night would be 5
was so good he just lost a couple of
temples yeah maybe 995 was already a
mistake yeah
because after Queen d7 I don't know
maybe in 1994 if just just a curious
question I feel pretty nice beautiful
would you play Queen t6 all right good
good job that's the spirit you know well
we're just discussing this tournament
you know you have those rules you cannot
forgive or draw before 30 moves now you
come here you fly all the way from
Ukraine right a few hours I mean see you
want to see some some action right
that's a good job
so night 3 to d4 was played a 6th I
kicked his knight on a three yeah this
this night just can't find a place for
himself
rook 88 so now I really like blacks
position more and more 22 h5 and here is
what I saw so I was analyzing the game
and I said okay here's something went
wrong like probably he had just to play
d1 maybe Knight see to maybe bring the
knight somehow to before e3 yeah but
still
I guess so it was you yeah well you know
idea with h5 was maybe to push h2 or
something yeah to push h3 at some point
and I wanted to make a move to make a
window for the king okay make sense a
because what what do you okay it would
be one yeah sketchy yeah I didn't expect
I say I think probably he was already
you know as frayed of this battery
Brooks but I think maybe if you will
play if you play route 81 then bring it
but still it's not so easy to play with
Wyatt
especially the under temperature right
so go truck old e to D one Queen to c7
and Queen to f2 and this moment we begin
the March of the night yeah but
afternoon a 97 he had to play nicely to
of course and then I can play 95 because
of night before AHA and d5 is saying
yeah this wasn't after a nice it'll
maybe 96 the and then put my Knight to
c4 mmm
yeah yeah so the major problem was the
snack yeah you just left it there yeah
I'm starting ninety five ninety three so
I guess it was the only option
yeah it's strange because he played this
movie right yeah I guess he wanted to
play a four but after 95 my night is
coming to this three night and night DT
so we have one two three moves formulas
I was just telling our viewers at home
that you know usually you don't want to
move the same piece twice especially in
the opening but here I mean you see this
night coming form of six two is such a
aggressive square on d3 I mean it looks
just beautiful over there yeah but you
know my night one of six was kind of bad
right because of the deftly yeah because
of strange yeah so good tonight
two three queen G two and nine take some
B - wow what an amazing sacrifice and I
remember will we I was looking at this
position and action Chanda only had only
one minute on the clock with the
pressure and I said okay I'm not gonna
take this night Abby - I believe you
you're gonna you know you know after
Luke takes between takes history and
thinking yeah everything is just as
collapsing after that Queen takes yeah
everything is collapsing it's very
difficult to calculate in just one
minute so that's why I played f4
probably to defend this despondency -
yeah
Knight d2 d3 the neither knife comes in
the eye the position is just and I can
fact that all of your pieces is just a
connective very very nice you know he
took on here and I had to consider a
very precise precise move I assume also
I said that when he was in time trouble
even even at this position although he
had just 30 seconds you took your time
you didn't really pay on time yeah well
you know I've already lost two
completely winning games I was trying to
be careful just to double-check yeah
good good yeah and we saw it in the mini
this tournament that people just like
try to play very fast and yeah so you
took on c3 and then pretty much the the
position has collapsed after f5 you took
the rocket pretty much here you could
take any piece probably but this was the
most obvious one take
Queen takes on d3 yeah I was thinking
also I mean you could take also be
tonight but here just if you take with
the knife maybe as some chances 9 to 5
yeah I didn't want to go yeah so after
Queen d3 you do that you you just not
supposed to some maybe some kind of end
game and obviously you know you guys
know that you know there's no no way for
him to save the game all right we're
good good job congratulations
who do you are could you play next do
you know I guess our own green bean ski
but I'm not sure okay yeah that's yeah
that doesn't matter who I'm gonna play
makes I'm just gonna play my best yeah
yeah this is at this moment so yeah so
good luck and what what what do you
usually do when after the game there you
go some I don't know if you guys have
any any team will do some fitness
exercise no I'm just walking you have a
pretty nice Park yes
yeah Forest Park yeah and their museums
cafes restaurants great so thank you for
joining us today
good luck in the rest of the tournament
and we are going to go into a quick
commercial break and so stay with us
we're gonna come back thank you
[Music]
[Music]
the question on Twitter from dem s I
should not have pronounced that that was
a bit of a champion for those of you who
are new to chess it might look like ba 3
is an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to squares not one but it
still is something we call hustle and
you can do that but you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move like
that 6 1917 g2 and now try because y'all
play four against Lawrence and now he's
going to play something against me which
we discussed at length during the course
of my stay
yeah he told me this is accent g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think he ficus1 know who
Lawrence this is not how chess works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chest actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of my quality of
life has just gone downhill tremendously
because I'm actually sharing the office
of the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't wanna
skip
[Music]
hello and welcome back to coverage of
round six for the 2018 is spring chess
classic I'm Ben Simon and I have a
thought in a mur
and we're finishing up coverage for this
round but there's still a whole lot
going on vitally including a game we
haven't even looked at yet oh yeah it's
in group a we haven't looked at Lazaro
Brazil against Alexandra epitope was so
busy with all the decisive games that we
had I mean this yeah so yep so we will
see what is going on on that board as
you can see at time temperature got the
passage as the time control of the Foley
moves it's four move number 42
we are in an endgame very interesting
material equality but White has to spawn
on c6 and White is attacking this Bishop
on f4 f5 so is it white advantage black
will probably need to move the bishop
not to lose the bishop my son lose the
bishop there should be six now the
question is if I move my pawn to c7 nice
sacrifice my bishop after a three let's
let's do this
take take and a two
this might be a very interesting end
game to play hmm I'm not sure this this
requires a lot of lots and lots of
calculation basically Black's idea is
just to promote the Queen if I'm coming
that's a queen c1 then black can play
Queen b1
how are you going to deny me from
getting a second Queen I do not see a
way unless we have some checks I start
to create some checks before that Queen
a5 check but the king can find some
cover maybe on h6 or I can even play
just g6 started just to play g6 Queen h3
check King g7 oh I'm sorry
almost blundell my queen luckily I'm not
playing this game
so Queen to h3 but now I can just
exchange and obviously I will Queen
after a one so that gets to the
interesting question carosone force a
draw like a repetition that that is what
I was trying to create so after a two we
have I see only one checking on the five
but now you can play black and just play
g6 and well in this case white can play
Queen f6 and defenders a1 square
let's see that so far as the board in
just the case to get a better picture
like did play Bishop e6
and we see on the video does Arizona is
thinking about his movies like what are
you thinking should I push 7 or should I
try to fight against this pawn on e4 or
another option is to take the spot on g5
decisions decisions
indeed elsewhere in Group A I have to
mention that a result that we had
speculated would happen has come to
fruition as the French Grandmaster Roman
Edouard has defeated Alexander ownership
of the United States
with the white pieces yeah so so that's
a Edwards first victory over anybody in
this event and that's ownership first
loss yeah yeah you know I have noticed
something today I have to say that well
actually I don't want to say that but I
think I think that the youngsters are
playing quite good right now in tens the
question you know why and I think you
know it as we go to the last rounds the
players are more exhausted and you know
age you know age is doing his thing so
yeah it's an endurance game I mean you
don't think of it whenever you see just
chess on the marquee right but yeah it
is and there's no red state here from
the start we were talking about jet lag
and now we're just talking about the
hammering of this five hour games every
day yeah right now I mean romana édouard
27 years old over ona shook who I
believe is 42 yeah that did yeah so yeah
the young man's game yeah so definitely
it's as well it will be better for
somebody who still stay in shape I know
that I was traveling a lot during my
life and that lots of opinions about
no just lairs now they're viewed and you
know lots of people think that you know
chess players we just you know play
chess all day long in our rooms but
actually lots of the chess players are
much more active you can see in the last
10 to 20 years that the top chess
players in the world kind of being
replaced by those youngsters when you
see more young stars we just look at
here
Geoffrey Zhang is he's living at his
group and yeah we see all those
youngsters starting to beat all the
experienced masters so so yeah so
definitely I think that endurance and
activity is taking a part in that I have
been told we're going to hear from
priyadarshan canna pan who today in
Group B became one of the four games to
win as black as he defeated Alexander
fear so you know both of these players
they've played in these tournaments
before here at the club these classics a
classic veteran if you will so we look
forward to hearing from priyadarshan and
that means we only have three games left
three games going live here all right
let's look at this so yeah Ganguly
versus darius rich very intensely action
yeah so let's see we started to look at
the oil at the opening but let's see it
at the current position first of all I
gotta tell you again what stands out to
me is the time Darius is only four
minutes and so yeah good good he with 45
minutes this is after they have made the
time control so that's it there's no
more time Adam except the 30 seconds
pair move white made this move g4
basically white is trying to exchange as
many points as possible so if black
takes on g4 white is going to take on e4
and
really weakening the black king on h7 so
what should black to black is probably
thinking what am I supposed to do here
although Darius has last time it does
look like this pawn on e5 is is a major
threat I mean just think about this if
it's some key in some in some moment
white we'll exchanges heavy pieces at
the Queen and the rook this pawn on on
the a file is just going to be
unstoppable so maybe this is what white
idea is to somehow exchange all the all
the pieces and get in some kind of an
endgame so let's see so right now after
g4 what ask him black do I mean can I
have the Fanta spawn into G just six
probably not maybe even h5 might follow
I'm not sure to be able to be quite
frank it is not such an easy position
for black to play so we will definitely
go back to this to this game going to be
very very interesting especially in time
trouble but right now we have another
guest
we have PD joining us again yeah all
right
two wins in a row congratulations yeah
alright you really wanted to be on there
again I mean ask them because they said
yeah sure all right perfect
do you think that your family is
watching your friends are watching
online maybe someone from Webster so
some some teammates are watching we
haven't looked at your game too much but
we were just saying that you were one of
the for the size of games that and the
team be it will be and all of them were
won by black yes I believe black pieces
day right yeah that's true yeah you're
on the a group I think everyone with
black
right road of black ones today yeah
exactly so let's go over the game real
quick yeah you play the black against
Alexander of fear yeah so he started
with this move see 40 normally plays d4
so it it was slight surprise but I kind
of expected it though so c5 and then I
c3 Knight see Knight f3 knight c6 Knight
c3 I think he didn't expect me to go if
a surprise for him and then he played he
3 f5 d 4e 4 and here are the mean mu I
think it's Knight g14 efore D favors
more leads to more equal positions so he
played t5 I think IG 1 is more for a
game and so keeping more pieces on the
board yeah and then the night rig routes
to export a usually soft D 44 usually we
get to some kind of an end game if I'm
not mistaking now you take that was the
game but you had to take D takes c6 f G
tows a mistake there so d take C 6 was
the game too and there's a game I think
Cara wanna was a son Gary from Cinco
fill Cup 2016 where they reach the same
game Queen D it can be a GF 3 and Gary
equalized easily with black and then
game so that's what I thought he would
be I mean he didn't know I guess this
theory because he started to thing and
he went for Queen takes f3 which I
vaguely remember is not the best mode
surprising that black's pawn structure
is actually kind of weak but black has a
lot of play on the central squares and
so black has a pretty good position
especially widescreen on f3 is kind of
misplaced right yeah and almost looks
like you are the one who is holding the
D file for right now yeah and I really
like you your space advantage this this
fauna5 is usually not so good when this
case is like it doesn't it doesn't know
how Y to do anything so I think it's
really thanks to see fix bone orders the
D Phi would have created a shoes for
their fight
you know the weakness combined three six
and F I worked out pretty well yeah nice
six and here he went for this idea of
long castling which was sharp but I
think it was the best for white I think
you should just try to short castle and
try to slowly develop maybe Bishop e2
short castle and room d1 yeah things
like that yeah but he went for those
ideas long castling which i thought was
that Ike was more free for me like
easier to play than this yeah Bishop b2
Bishop e7 and then long castle short
castle yeah the problem is although your
queen is aligned in front of the rook
but even if you move the bishop well
where is it
Bishop - right right we can just we just
move our queen so it's not so dangerous
for and I don't want to move my queen
also because when no my queen has be
sure gets to d3 and he attacks fire
that's why I kept my queen on d8 because
I wanted him to waste a tempo if he
wants to like go Bishop d3 mm-hmm so let
him go everyone and then go but then he
loses some coordination of his pieces
yeah yeah perfect so castle yeah very
great Queen of H 3 and then Bishop e6
here and Queenie - I realized it's going
to go for our time with g4 because
because g4 straight away without Queen
e2 then I think I'll just take F G for
Queen e2 then I had some I don't know
like here because the Bishop a4 so he
deserve to go Queen e2 first and here
okay here was a big choice for me fight
I had two moves a six or Queen e8 and I
played a six in the game
Queenie it also looked pretty
interesting because I was trying to put
my Queen on f7 at some lines attacking
c4 sometimes going to g6 and you know
defending my King side but I realized
okay so going to be erased let me play
six and go for the tag yeah yeah nice
and he went g4 b v GF v had a very
tricky position if I should take on c4
or f5 I think now that I played Bishop
c4 I think I mean I feel Bishop f5
should have been better because Bishop
c4 was very more messier than I expected
it to be and if you take on f5 is I
think it's going to go clean f3 most
probably that's this plan and then maybe
go queen g2 but I have a lot of pieces
to defend my king and especially is
Bishop on d 2s and coming into
that easily so I think I should be able
to have a huge advantage in this
position on the other hand when you take
on c4 you all of this
those those punching is just coming over
yeah that's true that's what I was
hoping for but surprisingly a mr.
resource were right in this game so he
played Queen f3 and her initially I
thought of Bishop f1 but the N game
wasn't good for me because Bishop f1 if
he plays it takes with Luke H F 1 B 492
Queen d 5b v 492 Queen d5 Queen d5c d5
Knight f4 ss this person made very
slightly better for me but not enough to
like it's not easy for me to get that
five pawn because D Phi is always
hanging so I thought I don't want to go
into this from a position like that I
decided let me go and like you know have
some fun with all my pieces so I decide
to fight HS I mean if you if you are
both attacking you want to keep the
Queens on the board yeah and see see
what happens
yeah so I said I played I shouldn't have
seven and then rubgy one here I can I
miscalculated a bit so he played queen
g2 which I expected and I played 98 and
main was that I considered at 94 and 92
but I completely miss Queen c6 when I
played an ID 8 PC it's very strong the
idea is if I play B takes c3 if I take
the knight Bishop takes c3 and then if
you go screen if I go Queen c8 which is
kind of like one of only move Queen G to
know there's an Queen g2 and if I play
Queen f5
yes Bishop d3 and I'm just losing this
position oh yeah now it's all these
pieces are coming in yeah a piece is not
enough for me to do anything in this
position yeah so and then I went into
like a deep thing here and my underlying
that I calculus queen c8 but the issue
with Queen C 8 is runs into Knight d5
and then I'm like losing this line to
more or less than most variations
position so it is that okay so no direct
threats are working so I decided I found
this nice no root k7
very happy about it I just leave the
night and leave my queen everything I
just move the rook the point is that my
thought is to go rook d7 and then
threatened to take on c3 so I put
pressure on D to the base that's like
overall point of this whole line and
after ok7 I think he played Knight d5
which was a bit surprising looks like it
sounds like your fate facing the fear
and I look at in the eyes like you don't
you're not scared about this rope here
and we can this Queen over here v8 yeah
okay whatever you do I'm not scared
[ __ ] happy you won and I think he
missed a nuance he I wasn't sure how
good roopd sevinor's was very
interesting route d7 I was going to play
Bishop f6 Bishop f6 okay the point is if
he plays rook a7 then I have B takes c3
and then this look like I should be
winning somehow oh but the odd line here
that I think was very sharp was instead
of Route 87 he played ruk f7 was very
interesting for white takes yeah so if I
play rook takes f7 like rook a f7 now
here's Bishop c4 b takes c3 bishop f7
and if I play rook f7 he has Queenie a
true cat faith Queen e6 and I thought
here was better the same game and I was
like okay if he finds this I have to go
into this I didn't have any much chance
but but obviously I had to find rook d7
and followed up with drew capture and
which were two and of not-so-natural
I thought and he played Knight d5 which
was good enough but not I think not that
a strong as rook d7 so here I decided to
take on a two and ninety seven rookie
seven Queen a6 yeah to me it looks like
you penetrated his his castle first
yeah um so it looks please yo King he
just looks so so safe over here with all
those pieces and there's this Queen
Queen come he comes in gates of chaos
exactly so and but he had he s Queen a6
now so it kind of forces Queen Trey it's
more or less if I pull back my Queen
then I think he gets bit some sort of
correctly but where they pull back my
queen maybe beat three maybe that's my
best right but then he has moves like f6
maybe even nice yeah on no f6 I think
was running for Knight f6 Queen f6 Queen
d1 but still this question I think is so
I decided I I realized I had like four
minutes and clock and had to make 15
moves and is that it better to just
exchange the Queen's and I thought the
same game was better because as bishop
on e1 is very bad yeah very practical
decision yeah okay okay seven Bishop b3
and here I had to go Knight f6 if I
wanted to push for again because I want
to take a draw I could go Bishop b3
Bishop c2 Rukia Munsch I can't exchange
everything and take on f5 but that would
most probably end in a draw because
that's like what money four pawns left
on the board with the rope down so I
mean it's interesting to see that
although you are pawn down and he has
two bishops yeah you still have the
advantage yeah I have demonstrator with
me which is all thanks for my b4 pawn
which is restricting the even bishop
right yeah chef c3 comes the game's
literally over I think wait you just
take the illustrator yeah so every
Knight f6 and here he started playing
pretty I think he started playing on my
clock you start moving pretty fast so f3
Bishop b3 Bishop c2 are okay one King
beat when I went into this lane I missed
this neurons after roopd when I really
saw Bishop D when I missed King do you
want so and then I'm like okay I had to
recalculate everything and then had to
go to be eight I had to go into this
line King eater Bishop c4 we should be
three looks like you are hugging his
King yeah but the line group d3 doesn't
work the point is if I play rook takes
d3 Duke takes d3 rook b1 he has king d2
and if I play rook takes me to he has
Kings he want I say and then if I play
Bishop d3 King d3 instead of rook takes
b2 then he has efore you know there is a
pawn starts rolling that's kind of a
sharp battle where I think he should be
favored because he has the bishop I
think he should so I decided I will take
the you know exchange up even though it
was complicated this person what sure if
I'm better is just unclear in my opinion
here again had a huge looking at they
talking 8/8
King f8 look more practical because I
knew the e pawn
gonna start running but then I saw some
ghost lines with e4 Bishop f2 and
bishops if I checked and all that
talking h8 is more safe for a bit like
one less than one minute on the clock it
didn't ever know yeah I don't want to
get checkmated something oh yeah so I
decided to go King h8 and then he found
this movie for which obviously it's the
best man here yeah and then I did I know
I had to play rook c1 which was critical
or else he is going to go some sort of
Bishop f2 next no yes I saw this
disposition live and I said it I really
like that there you can see one you want
to bring your other of the D file yeah
but I also said never underestimate the
power of the bishops so it's kind of
tricky yeah and then B 3 group so now
after I double the rooks there's no way
the bishop and rook is kind of getting
out I think the only said that where he
could get out as if he puts his King on
f2 and record f1 and put the bishop on
e2 and then but that's kind of he has to
spend 3 for most but then I think when I
couldn't become active so I played rugby
1 and he went he five-night h5 e 6 and
here I couldn't calculate because night
as for was the move initial intent to
play but the line that kind of wasn't
sure was Knight f4 King III
Ruki - oh sorry Dukie one rookie one
night g2 rookie no I first plain IG to
check right yeah and the King has to do
if I go nighty 1 I lose because of e 7
so if my King was an exile in this line
I win but that's the difference
yes I love my things yeah and then even
the funny thing is if I play rook e1 why
it doesn't even have to take on I think
doesn't have to take on g2 maybe he can
even go Bishop e2 I don't know if that
works
oh oh maybe now I just give up my ro can
go Knight f4 night defend defended
Bishop e2 I have okay even the worst
case and if I take the nice yeah this is
I think most probably should be a draw
or my children this because I think is
going to come out
I think it's kind of stuck there and he
any he wants to play probably a king f2
and f4 and it was people keep it exactly
a file and then yeah so I saw this and I
decided okay this is too messy and I
wasn't sure if I would be able to win
this in any way so I decided I'll just
go back now at least that fauna smooth
father away so Knight f6 I can manage
stop said so nice yeah and here he
picking f2 I went through k1 because I
wanted the route potentially to swing
paid at some lines and then Bishop be
fair was a mistake he he just must King
g8 completely no my king comes into the
game yeah I'm all in this thing will be
maybe e7 for him start upon no e7 then I
go route k7 and I pick up the pond I
then I just try to take the pawn and
then I'll exchange the rooks and then
I'll just try to like you know use my
extra like unless something like Bishop
c3 works which I yeah this is an
interesting I'm sure c3 it's a very
complicated so g1 Bishop f6 and I don't
know how I'm going to stop a screen
without dropping oh maybe I could go to
k-8 but then yes Kim Ji Won
right cuz GF 6 years Bishop b5 I
actually lose this endgame I'm a beast
on so instead of root k7 I may have to
do figure out something else then yeah
there were some sort of these tricks the
whole time and I wasn't so free so I
assume Bishop b5 is muda well 36 I
assume we were kind of in time pressure
pressure both of you guys he had like
more time than we had like 5 minutes I
believe in her like I was playing in 30
increment at this point more or less
yeah so now you're bringing your King
back yeah and after on so and now the
King is a good you know defending them
yeah and here it was funny rooks e1
everything move 38 and I said like a
trap basically if he goes Bishop c4 he
loses instantly stuff kingly to group
takes c4 BC for b3 and there's no way
he's stopping my pawn from home or
promoting so you went king d2 and it
decided to repeat once to get some time
on the clock and
then here he went back King D - and I
wasn't sure if I was going to do it
three times or not or smoke 39 I decided
okay why not
don't take the chances man is so good
good for you oh yeah okay yes fate and
even if I don't want to accidentally
even make a threefold repetition at any
point and this point looking at fate and
then yeah Bishop c4 it was exactly no 40
and I had to find that I think the
knight g8 it looks like he doesn't have
much much of a plan like there should be
five Bishop c4 like he's just waiting
one of his ideas to go east 7 next move
King e7 drug g7 King f8 rook f7 check
and that he may have some drawing
challenges that endgame but luckily I
found this more Knight G a the point is
if he goes east 7 e7 then I take with a
knight I take with a king then there's
Bishop h4 and I lose so and if I if I go
instead of 98 if I go night he ate I
still lose that because e 7 check and
there's also some lines for exact
there are some lines where I was
actually if it was something like Knight
h5 mm-hmm I lose because of Bishop f2
rook g1 Bishop c5 check King e8 Bishop
b5 checking D 87 so it's nice sometimes
to see all the losing lines because they
can choose the only surviving line I
guess so good so nigh g8 f6 wow he's
really pushing for you so the idea is if
I play GF 6 then it's rook g8 King jt7
and he makes a queen right that's the
idea but I take back with a knight and
e7 check King e8 we shall be fine and
now I take on e7
King a goes nice move yeah and we should
be fighting he seven route g7 King f8
and route g1 here
95 and here I'm sorry rook e1 check
first that was critical because I was he
was going to go Bishop e2 and after
Knight d5 I think he should have gone
thing as to he played Bishop c4 but I
thinking as to was giving him some hope
the point is that if I go Knight f4 he
has rook g4
but still it's still be winning night h3
check usually d3
yeah something somehow I should be able
to win this yeah it's just a matter of
technique yeah the problems that he has
to bishops but one of them is completely
exactly I think he just like thrown the
towel here by going into this line where
I have Knight G to check an end of the
line maybe I'm full Roca okay well good
game you want with one with the black
pieces next I'm gonna be playing white
yeah again for a bit it's probably gonna
prepare hopefully for you win and you
know they say that the last three rounds
are the ones who decide you know the
where are you gonna be in the standings
very important so there's a good luck in
you thank you thank you and we are going
to go into a short commercial break and
we're going to it and after that a
moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chest 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chest
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience hi I'm Mike Matheny
whether you play chess for fun or want
to boost your child's academic
performance come visit the Chess Club
and scholastic Center of st. Louis right
here in the chest capital of the u.s.
from a welcoming diverse environment to
a Scholastic outreach program now in
over 100 schools our Center across from
the world chess Hall of Fame the Central
West End has it all so whether you've
played for years or never before we
invite you to experience all chess has
to offer
and welcome to our wrap-up of round
number six for the 2018 spring chess
classic I'm Ben Simon and I thought a
namer and we have three games still
going on but we will take a look first
at the standings before we go of the top
group the Masters if you will with just
two games still being played live on US
chess champs calm
Vitaliy your assessment of the games
that are still going on what are we
likely to see yeah as far as I as I see
here on the board a very spirit is
playing against so yeah Ganguly they
have some kind of a Queen's endgame but
I do feel like Darius is the one who has
the upper hand he might he might win
this although he has only a minute on
the clock so there is might witness and
Alexander epitope is playing as long as
a bruise on that is probably going to be
ending in a draw
again if Telus wins this he's gonna have
three and a half point
so maybe Darius will be the only player
who might fight against Jeffrey is lead
on the top of there someone within range
of Geoffrey right
tomorrow we can take a quick glance at
the games that are happening in this
division tomorrow these games start at 1
p.m. Central time on us chess champs
calm okay
and as far as Group B we have live
standings there there is only one game
still in progress that's Corbett's and a
lemur on D in your assessment in that
game yeah so on the go of it and JJ
Maroni it looks like it's going to be a
draw they are playing it's not it's kind
of like an end game still I did like
Andres position a little bit more but it
looks like a JJ
he is making some progress and
especially under his time he has only
four minutes for the rest of the game
and JJ has 21 minutes so I actually I
think it might might be open but
probably why as a right now it looks
pretty equal I it's very tough to place
a bet on that game
well if it will end the draw we will see
a change at the top with Andre Gaurav
it's being at a table with Malik
kutcheon indeed and the pairings per
round number 7 tomorrow starting at 1:00
p.m. on us chess champs calm this is
group B yeah okay can't wait for
tomorrow it should be a fun time and
remember each day here at the chess
campus we will be bringing the coverage
to you for about 90 minutes sometimes
two hours starting at 3:30 p.m. Central
Time two and a half hours after the
start of the round but you can catch the
round as it happens at 1:00 p.m. at the
u.s. chess champs calm and chess 24 this
broadcast was presented by the world's
greatest production B team Dennis LaRue
was our interview man and making sure
that the stream was healthy today Isaac
Krantz is on graphics and sound Dani
Machuca is the technical director my
name is Ben Simon and I'm without a
murmur and until tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
we say so long from the Show Me State
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you
you